this is your bedroom now
[Music]
this is incredible hi everyone it is so
important to me as we all embark on this
journey together that we pull back the
curtains so you can see
what goes into creating our spaces on
the show and right now
we get to talk about one of my favorite
things
design
[Music]
when i found out that we were making
this show i knew design was going to be
a huge part of it and so
designed by drew was born
and in this segment we're creating
incredible spaces
for incredible people i wish i could hug
you guys wish i could squeeze you
and right now i am so excited to be
designing a space for a very deserving
mom
of two named karen hi
my name is karen mckechnie i live in
scarborough maine i live here with my
two
fantastic little boys jack and drew who
are six and nine
ian and i did a lot of work to this
house putting a lot of love
into pretty much every single room
except for
our master bedroom
karen lost her husband two years ago to
cancer but despite
everything she continues to exude
love and positivity and examples
so we're gonna transform her current
bedroom
into the master bedroom she has always
talked about doing
take a look at us designing her space
i love the like her seeing herself
in the morning and before she walks out
the door
she has earned that
you know moment
[Music]
we're going with the carson bed
it's a nice okay i'm embedding now
perfect
i love this color blue
it could be nice to give her multiple
throws too i
i was thinking the same thing i need
pillows
almost oh and then
i'm gonna do the mason and the
cumberland spots
you know we'll see which one looks
if the wall is bigger also maybe the
mason works and if the
wall space is a little tighter then
maybe the cumberland
yeah it's so crazy oh
i noticed that she has a lamp
on the dresser i'd love to get a
measurement
of that current dresser she has
mixed so we can match it to the one you
found
because look look at this little lamp
the beach side table lamp
it's short and won't fight the painting
and make
give that light source that she feels
that she needs because there's a lamp
there anyway and it's true that corner
doesn't have any light
this was your bedroom
okay this is your bedroom now
i love designing this space so much
we always tailor it to the person and
this is just the beginning
our biggest hope with this segment is
that we give great people a great space
that they can love
and i want them to feel all the love
that goes into it when we're creating it
[Music]
you